it's Tuesday April 5th and as of  tomorrow April 6th ps4 update 3.5 will  be out in the wild as usual it's adding  some new features to Sony's latest  console but one of the new additions may  come as a pleasant surprise with update  3.5 you'll be able to use Remote Play on  your PC or Mac Remote Play is compatible  with Windows 8.1 Windows 10 OS X 10.10  and 10.11 depending on your bandwidth  you'll be able to play games between 360  and 720 p with frame rates at 30 or 60  frames per second other new features  include options to appear offline C when  certain friends come online schedule  play sessions with your friends and  stream to dailymotion update 3.5 sounds  like one of the biggest changes yet ps4  update 3.5 releases Wednesday April 6 in  the meantime you can dabble with the  latest PlayStation Plus lineup to see if  any of April's free games are up your  alley and for all the PlayStation news  you could want you're already in the  right place